you are high-risk because of how you say
feds and much age hey man I know you
just moved here from like the Ukraine or
whatever but in this country when you
call them and fat and old that's
considered rude I mean not pure where I
come from sis compliment you not
understand fit like big happy face
lots of meats for the baby this mansion
you give 275 any guesses on what that
number means how many hours I've been
sitting here that's the number of women
I've had sex with now I'm sure some of
you are saying how can a man who has
sinned so many different ways and
positions how can a man with a sleeve of
tattoos a man who did drugs crazy drugs
how can that man be in charge of your
spiritual guidance
well Mike's done everything I mean
confessing him will be a breeze
God comes to us in many ways for st.
Paul it was a bolt of lightning on the
road to Damascus for me was Keith
Richards they found me on his bathroom
floor of his house which I had broken
into and he said to me you got it
together guys all right Danny can you
tell me what this is all about are you
kidding me you let the nurses call you
Danny here okay I just didn't I'm sorry
doctor see not all the nurses just Sarah
cos she's also my girlfriend I want to
do a little exercise I want you to tell
us five things you find beautiful about
your penis hey you guys mind if I go
kill myself Danny this is sex therapy
we're supposed to talk about sex or in
our case lack thereof okay okay well
that's private between me and you I need
a need a what now this isn't gonna work
unless you're open for example
Christina's ironic Journal was
comprehensive suspenseful and frankly
moving thank you well yours on the other
hand
it's just a rant about airport security
and a trick play for the Jets now let's
talk about your sperm notice their
behavior they're listless they're
unhappy they're apathetic but they are
perfectly healthy then why'd you say all
that other stuff first just the way I
talk every couple weeks I buy a ticket
and hang out in the lobby of the Empire
State Building to see if I will meet my
one true love captain she's back so you
come here regularly
it's a monitor the base of the building
I'm here to meet that special summon and
when I do we're gonna go to the top and
then BOOM
fireworks and who is that person I
haven't met him yet but I can tell when
I find him we are going to spend
eternity together could you describe all
right well he's been 30s he has tall
dark intense mysterious you understand
why what you're telling us will cause us
serious concern yeah I can't help it you
know even though it's dangerous because
I am a true believer hey we're gonna
need Miller from Homeland Security
Homeland Security that's a close yeah
why do you have a bag with a passport
three cellphones okay well this is for
the Internet this is for texting and
flip phone is because I do not know how
to transfer my old contacts you know
we've been spending so much time talking
about me that I haven't asked you
anything what are you into protecting
this ability I'm so old-fashioned you
have great facial hair I love a guy with
a beard can I touch it hands on the
table please hey it's cool if you're
into me Kevin Garnett once bought me a
coke got a PF Changs not helping
yourself I'm just saying I don't see a
wedding ring is there a mrs.
Confederated security solutions oh my
god you could have just said yes moment
was such a fun idea T I love modern art
music
I feel like if they're less intimidating
because I think I could do the art oh
you're not your sticker actually leave
it I like people to know that I had a
more cultural day than they did oh it's
like the artsy version I voted oh yes I
have a ski-lift ticket on my parka from
two years ago when you teach Latin for a
living it helps to look like a huge
Jackson hi sorry I'm late
oh it turns out the defendants gang had
a copy of my home address became a thing
all right
they always threaten me nothing ever
pans that we believe what this girl
deals with yeah every day she looks
murderers in the eye and puts them in
prison for the rest of their lives so
important I mean speaking of stressful
situations I delivered a baby last night
he did not want to be born he was really
mad at me I'm glad he didn't have my
home address that's really funny hey
seriously though you know if you ever
fear for your safety you still have a
key if you ever want to stay at my place
you know you can right well I would
rather take on the Sinaloa cartel than
deal with the water pressure in this
guy's out it's not that bad it's not
that bad you are so great
you should tell the boyfriend I would
love to meet a cool guy except all the
guys I meet are either nineteen-year-old
murderers or eighty-year-old judges no I
think I'm gonna find you someone no I
wouldn't try this girl is the pickiest
dater I have ever met in my life yeah
I'm actually a very good matchmaker well
I wish you luck but no one's ever good
enough for this girl so I wouldn't even
try it so maybe at the Museum
[Music]
you see that that's how good I am at sex
Oh No did I break it to Mariah Carey's
penthouse and fall asleep again it's me
it's Matt your husband ex-squeeze me
where's your cousin somebody looking for
cousin Shino
oh my god where did you come from and
it's since I've always been here what
she's messing with you she snuck in
while you were in the bathroom so Tamra
tells me you pregnant need to be careful
babies are shady they steal yo you think
you didn't keep it for their own damn
self
well that ship has sailed cousin Gina
were you three months ago on a cruise
not just the photo I don't even want to
have sex with my boyfriend how long's it
been two weeks
okay it is some so good to see you
I wish I could see you but I'm blind now
oh my god I'm not actually blind
that's a weird joke to make I don't know
why did that I'm sorry I was nervous to
see you so I thought I'd do a bit okay
here you know that book I was thinking
about it I'm only asking because I have
two bucks and you have one so if we
combine them I could get a tote bag but
why wouldn't I get the free tail back
cuz you're a guy what do you need a tote
bag for it
I can store all my tote bags I don't use
in it all right well I'm gonna go oh
lady
maybe she'll play ball yes what would I
even wear this out huh I'm thinking
joint custody you get the tote bag
during the week I'll take the tote bag
on the weekends yeah that I agree shall
we go Shakespeare yeah I don't support
Shakespeare I heard a story that he
didn't write any of his plays he made
his mother at the manager call the
credit so you're saying the butler did
it
that sounds pretty dumb but if it is
true is nothing most despicable thing
I've ever I've also learned that even
when you seek friendly advisory business
pros they can feel threatened by your
talent Kris Jenner hi
I started the Lahiri fertility clinic
again how did she get in here please
please a national treasure oh god I must
be getting delirious I'm starting to
question some of the choices I've made
in my life hey it's your girl Mindy
coming to you live from a cave I fell
into you can't get any internet so
whoever finds me and my phone you'll
have to upload it later and if I die
till the oh I love him until Morgan
declare my search history hey snap out
of it oh my god
Reese Witherspoon hey June you're in the
middle of the woods huh oh no you're in
rehab I knew it you know what if you can
help me out of here I will write you a
prescription for whatever you want no I
am here to teach you some hard truths
dummy hard truths no no pass I choose
dare I dare you to kiss me you're my
celebrity I'll pass oh that's so weird
cuz you're mine on Celebrity Hall Pass
really no that's not a thing and besides
why do you need a celebrity Hall Pass
you're not even dating anybody you're
divorced and single dan reese
witherspoon that's cool is no I thought
you supposed to be America's Sweetheart
Dutch you're supposed to give me advice
like I will find my one true love if I
give up my big-city ways and go back to
my down-home roots is that the plot of
Sweet Home Alabama yeah that is a movie
movies aren't real Mindy okay well if
movies aren't meal what about this one
it's called wild it says it's based on a
true story mm-hmm
did you read it no I I bought it because
you're on the cover and I I really like
this bob hairstyle on you if you had
read it or watch the movie you would
know that life isn't about finding a man
it's about finding yourself I'm going to
need to find myself I know where I am
Idaho Iowa Ohio life is not like the
movies Mindy you can't get into harvard
law school by submitting a videotape of
yourself in a bikini they also don't
shut down all of Tiffany's for one
wedding proposal and sometimes life
doesn't have a happy ending how dare you
your movies are a bunch of Lies and I
demand a refund
Bradley ticket than I've ever bought to
your films and for failure to launch
which you weren't even in you know what
I'm gonna leave you here you clearly
have a lot of thinking to do you've
already done a lot of farting no that's
sulfur but I think it's sulfur from the
it's disgusting kill it Rhys you can
tell me can you at least run back to the
resort and grab me a soda not diet I'm
sorry Mandy I'm an apparition the real
Reese Witherspoon is wandering around
Brentwood Country Mart trying to
remember where she parked her car you're
gonna have to save yourself Mindy
goodbye please know what a badge Liberty
loose nation leash a pot
you